I don't wear machine so there's a
random-ass hose just sitting here and
we're just gonna make it rain
instead of doing cg rain thank god I
hate Caesar rain let's do found a booth
Sam today is director photography Sam
and today it is director Nico because
this is a piece that I end up writing
Sam was doing a bunch of other stuff the
illustrious Jake Watson is back to
reprise his role as demon this time with
demon buddies Ren and Carmichael
cameras rolling three two one actresses
or just maybe you should be trying magic
start off looking up higher and I like
tilt down and I thought I would go super
slow I feel like at least half the speed
you just went there
I just feel like inching forward like
that
all right so dealing with kind of tricky
shot here actually they're all tricky
shots here's a general idea I was
thinking about cool effects to do one
night and cloth simulations kind of came
to mind I started thinking something
pull you do with cloth simulations and I
realize that you could have this thing
where like somebody's running in a video
and just pause it and you cut out that
2d layer and make that a clock instances
playing with perspective and things that
were 3d are becoming flat and vice-versa
I realize is a good candidate for kind
of following up brush with death all
right hold on oh I'm sorry I'm not gonna
hold his hand oh my god I don't know
your whole head I know like what's up
but that's what we said about Ren
we saw his face
what is your name my name is Ren what is
your favorite color not green
I hate green what is the airspeed
velocity of an unladen swallow unladen
swallow in a dive
soaring catching a thermal look I don't
know that 42 so what we wanted to do for
this video was mess around with
perspective and in the original brush
with death video and even before that
the graphic violence so start off with
the graphic violence which is like a
prospective 2d thing put images on a
wall have them interact it's cool take
that to the next level make it
perspective shift that's brush with
death and now it's like what can we do
differently that still plays around with
perspective it's like alright let's have
a person projected onto a paper and then
fall so they in one moment their person
moving around 3d they're obviously not
paper in the next moment they are paper
and they fall down flat the challenge is
to make a cloth simulation that works
with this
great all right so to do this effect
we're using this program called 3ds max
it's just a modifier it's not some fancy
simulation plugin it's just like it
takes a bunch of polygons and takes the
vertices and just makes them as if
they're cloth so we're going to do a
quick little super simple tutorial
walkthrough on how to do a cloth
simulation so if I go to the front view
here and draw a spline go to shapes and
draw a line I'm just going to draw the
simplest person ever just like hey look
at me I have a very swollen arm and
triangular head kind of like hey Arnold
with the big really long arm over here
and then yeah close fine yes and I'm
going to just move them up so he's above
this line here I'm going to draw a box
there for the ground plane yeah I'm
going to modify it by adding garments
maker all that does is just adds
polygons specifically triangles to your
thing and you can change the density of
the triangles and I like to go for about
this density and then I like to relax it
just because I think I might get better
results but I might not who knows so
once you do that you have essentially a
cloth and you're ready to simulate it
but first you got to go to convert to
editable poly and now you can play
around with this so let's go to cloth
and add our cloth modifier sweet so
we've added it so obviously for the
video I would actually pull up a
background image from the video and
outline the person I know but I like
looking at you your face is so pretty
Carmichael it's like hey hey okay where
did I leave off we actually have to add
things for the cloth to interact with
like the ground so I'm just going to go
back to our little shaped primitives
thing here and draw a box row box
sweet go to object properties and we're
going to add our box here hit add I'm
going to hit OK because some whatever
reason it like glitches out if you add
it and try to do other things so add it
hit OK and then go back and add other
things so I'm going to go back to object
properties here turn into a cloth and
you can choose whatever preset you want
let's go with a let's go with just
cotton typical cotton sweet and let's go
to our box here and it's important that
you make it a collision object hit OK
sweet and now the basis for our
simulation has begun so if I actually
hit simulate it's just going to fall
down
cool that's yeah that's that's a cloth
for you it falls down and doesn't do
much so for a video like ours where we
want to actually have them do things you
have to add things into the simulation
which makes it more complicated because
you don't ever get what you want you
have to affect you know wind gravity
you're not supposed to affect gravity
but sometimes you have to like change
how much gravity is in the shot all
these things contribute to a simulation
that does whatever it wants to do and
you don't know what it's gonna do until
you actually see it I wish there is a
button that was called fix it you press
that button and go home it doesn't work
like real physics does it tries to but
it doesn't if you think about reality is
like the highest quality simulation
possible and this is just trying to get
to that if you wanted to simulate the
highest quality it'll take forever
where's reality it doesn't install so
obviously I didn't really go over too
much in that tiny little tutorial I went
over but if you're a patreon subscriber
and you are subscribed for the online
tutorials as we've been doing for last
several videos I'm going to take you
from beginning to end on how to do this
exact shot actually do the camera Maps
onto a character and have it fall and
rendering it out and actually getting
like a nice shadow pass for it and
getting it to look really nice so
subscribe to patreon and I'll make a
nice tutorial for you
[Music]
and then I at one time
oh one time I hit simulate and the whole
thing just starts freaking out just like
crunching in on itself then pieces
getting stretched out to oblivion and I
literally just sat there and was like
why I have what